irán no permitirá la inspección de sus
instalaciones nucleares el organismo
internacional de la energía atómica no
ha logrado ampliar su acuerdo con
teherán y este fin de semana esperó el
monitoreo acordado por tres meses la
agencia tenía un plazo de tres meses que
llegó a su fin ayer su tiempo se ha
acabado y según la ley todas las
grabaciones deben ser borradas el 21 de
febrero el organismo de control nuclear
de naciones unidas- se irán lograron un
compromiso para verificar el programa y
las instalaciones nucleares iraníes con
inspectores en el lugar
el pacto estipulaba que si en ese plazo
eeuu no había levantado las sanciones
sobre la nación persa los datos
recopilados no serían entregados a la
oea
[Música]
la ley estratégica debe cumplirse
definitivamente de acuerdo con el
calendario establecido en ella
y el líder supremo también lo ha
recalcado muchas veces el plazo del 22
de mayo que marca el final del lapso de
3 meses debe cumplirse después de esos 3
meses el organismo internacional de la
energía atómica no tendrá
definitivamente derecho a acceder a las
grabaciones de las cámaras ni a
transferidas
el acuerdo temporal tenía por objetivo
garantizar una vigilancia mínima de las
instalaciones iraníes en medio de las
cada vez más complejas conversaciones
diplomáticas en viena para salvar el
acuerdo nuclear firmado en 2015 que se
reanudarán la próxima semana